[Music]
it is not a good day to be Nancy Pelosi
the Democratic leader coming under fire
for two comments made just today as
lawmakers from both parties try to work
together to reach an agreement on a deal
to protect dreamers the House Minority
Leader took the debate to a brand new
love complaining that negotiations were
being led by five white guys just stay
tuned stay tuned I would say of that
McCarthy the four four the five white
guys that called them you know I said
they you know open up hamburger stand
and next door what the that could have
been done four months ago
the very idea that this week they're
saying oh why don't we get four white
guys and general Kelly to come and do
this the number two Democrat in the
House Steny Hoyer quickly rebuked those
comments calling them offensive but if
that wasn't enough Pelosi then went on
to rip tax reform with this comment in
terms of the bonus that corporate
America received versus the crumbs that
they are giving to workers to kind of
but the schmooze Owen is so pathetic
it's so pathetic with all due respects
miss Pelosi I'm sure that $1,000 is more
than just crumbs to the working class
you pretend to fight for all right so
let's start with the the white guys
Kimberly right I guess the joke was the
five guys the hamburger chain my napkin
burger right but there's a clear racial
implication there helpful or not helpful
well not helpful right I mean look she's
got one laugh I think late a very late
laugh the way it was like a delayed
laugh track that somebody's like cue it
to save her career right I'm I think she
just realized probably afterwards it
wasn't the right thing to say and I
thought come on how many times do you
have to just take shots at white men I
mean is that is that the right thing to
do
not Nancy I'm saying you hear people
putting down disparaging white men doing
that whatever protests are going on
I don't know why she had to bring that
up cuz it doesn't I don't think it
serves any purpose and I don't think it
serves um you know her district and who
she's in charge of that they want to
hear comments like that to be quite
honest yeah why why are you always
picking on the white man you know
sometimes you think I've entered into an
alternative it was a poor joke right
because it got taken by people who want
to criticize her as being racially
loaded but here's the reality of it she
was making a joke about the five guys
hamburger chain right Kimberly said and
secondly what she's talking about is the
lack of diversity specifically the lack
of anybody with any Hispanic background
involved in these negotiations so nobody
for example the Congressional Hispanic
Caucus has a Thursday meeting today the
meeting breaks up because they don't
know what's going on they don't have
anybody in the meeting in fact the
people who were involved the four white
guys plus general Kelly the White House
chief of staff later asked senator
Menendez of New Jersey if he would come
because they were sensitive to the very
issue that Nancy Pelosi was one one look
I just asked us if there were five black
men there let's say from this
Congressional Black Caucus and she said
Oh looks like we have a basketball team
how would you take that what do you mean
because she said why is she said five
white she'd say five guys she said five
white guy yeah because this is about
immigration Greg and it's about
something that is specifically impacting
the Hispanic community in the United
States and there's nobody with any
background like that involved in it so
it's okay for liberals to inject race
and identity into everything it was like
that anybody made if anybody made a
similar joke like that from a Republican
side God knows the the amount of I think
you're just trying to say that there's
hypocrisy here at flip-flop right but
I'm saying to you I think there's a very
real argument here that she is speaking
to something that's a great concern to
many Americans not just Hispanic
American and those five what because
they are white they are incapable of
actually governing or doing something oh
come on that's what you say
I think it's 80% of the Congress is made
up of non of non female White's right so
I mean you forgot the word evil evil in
there okay it just proves to me that
that liberals Democrats are exempt from
their own moral high-ground
I mean I think Nancy was making a joke
but you did inject race into it but they
are allowed to be racist sexist and
homophobic because their heart is in the
right place right so you have Chelsea
Handler doing something genuinely
ghoulish to Lindsay Graham because she
believes her hearts in the right place
so they actually use a phony moral
high-ground to allow them to act
immorally calling money Donald Trump
would not refer to a thousand dollars as
crumbs and he's a billionaire
it's it's amazing to me that we can just
say that's okay there but it's not okay
there I'm fine with everything did you
have to be sensitive to the complexion
of any of the groups when we were in the
White House if you were doing something
on immigration did there have to be a
Hispanic there or was that something
that never crossed your mind it wasn't
difficult to have diversity in the Bush
administration I'm talking about like
like a Bushman is probably one of the
most they have the registrations might
be even more so than President Obama's
actually I think I think Bob Menendez
his voice is a good one in an important
one I do think that the split between
the Democrats on this is actually
interesting from a political standpoint
and their soup they're sensitive to it
and which is that's why Stanny Hoyer who
is the number two in the house under
Pelosi on the Democratic side like whoa
wait that's offensive because
significant you're just you know your
antenna is up the thing is though that
this announcement comes out today that
there's a deal but it's somebody says
it's a deal someone says we're close and
someone says we have a long way to go
that doesn't sound like a deal to me but
it's getting closer so the stakes are
higher and I think the one of the things
that the left is trying to do and not
artfully necessarily from Nancy Pelosi
sparked today but she knows that there's
a
fled in her caucus and she has to figure
out a way for the far-left to believe
that she is fighting for them and so
part of the way that you do that
sometimes is through rhetoric but
actually getting the deal and selling it
is going to be difficult for her caucus
but I think if they really want to solve
a problem and not perpetuate a problem
they're gonna have to take the deal but
we're not finished with miss Pelosi yet
do we still have the chroma gasps this I
think is much more significant than the
five white guys this makes her totally
out of touch I know she's what is she
worth what ninety million dollars or
something like that she's very been very
successful around counting successful
$1,000 it's a lot of money like Redd
said yeah that's anybody that's at least
one haircut for her I mean she's been
you know it's a lot of my color
she's a multi-millionaire mansion is
insane if you've ever seen her mansion
in California so she's it she calls five
figures of Krum and she's not even
Republican could you absolutely you
could and I don't think she knows I
think what they're trying to do is talk
about is try to show and what they
should probably do is try to show not
just tell that there is a big disparity
that the corporations are getting a got
a sweetheart deal from this tax reform
bill and that yes they are giving
significant bonuses all across or
they're raising wages or they're adding
paternity leave we're going to talk
about Walmart later in the show but it's
not artful and I think that the reality
of what's happening on the economic side
is really unfortunate for them the
President Obama wanted to do corporate
tax reform he wanted to go from the 35
rate down to 27 Paul Ryan was at a 25
and they could never actually get the
deal if they had gotten a deal they
would have been able to have economic
benefits like they're seeing now but
they chose not to you know I think you
guys are missing Hillary Clinton you
guys would be beating up on Hillary
Clinton so which opens your back when we
think arrived
because you guys need somebody you need
a white liberal female to beat up Nancy
because you say hey wait a second unique
this is so loathsome that even
Republicans don't like it focusing on
the tremendous ripoff and the money that
goes to the big pool you mentioned
Hillary will mention that crumbs oh my
god Nancy Pelosi called $1,000 crumbs
all that she said again if you look at
the whole statement was as compared to
the windfall going to the big voters
Herod they see a thousand dollars that's
grocery money that the rich are the ones
getting evil rich people they're
actually giving four with Walmart we're
talking about later four hundred million
dollars I guess for the workers that's
terrible see we're learning that that's
terrible yeah according to a liberal if
you actually give back to your workers
that's evil and wrong oh yes right
another episode of vino Juan Williams is
moving the goalposts but let me just say
for the record we don't think you're in
disparage white liberal women or look
for them to beat up on we talk about
people based on their qualifications and
the content of their statements the
facts or Mis statements that they make
and then we adjudicate them on that
that's what we do and we beat up on
President Obama who is not a white
liberal Perry Mason in the house